معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام
ماخر المعلومات المتوفره مع استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي على عده مناطق في قطاع
غزه بالفعل مياده هو قصف اسرائيلي على
مناطق مختلفه وعلى مخيمات مختلفه من قطاع
غزه البدايه من خانيونس حيث بدا عمليه
تموضع وتمركز او اعاده تمركز وتموضع للجيش
الاسرائيلي في مخيم خانيونس خاصه في
المناطق الغربيه من المخيم وبالتالي
استطاع سكان وسيارات الاسعاف والطواقم
الطبيه انتشال عدد من الجثامين من تلك
المناطق المناطق الغربيه لمخيم خانيونس
بالتحديد هذه المناطق الجيش الاسرائيلي
على ما يبدو اعاد التموضع والتمركز
وبالتالي انسحب من بعض المناطق وتمركز في
مناطق اخرى وبالتالي استطاع السكان في تلك
المناطق اجراء عمليات التمشيط بانفسهم
واجراء عمليات البحث عن الشهداء والبحث عن
ناجين ان كان هناك ناجين من جراء عمليات
القصف الاسرائيلي المستمره على هذا هذا
المخيم على مدار الايام الماضيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زال يقصف مدينه خانيونس
خاصه في الجهات الغربيه ما زال يقيم
الحواجز على الطريق الاساسي المؤدي من بين
من خانيونس الى مدينه رفح ايضا ما زالت
الدبابات الاسرائيليه تقصف بعنف المنازل
المدنيه الفلسطينيه في عده مناطق خاصه في
المناطق المحيطه بالمستشفيات الاساسيه
والرئيسيه في مدينه خانيونس مستشفى ناصر
وايضا مستشفى الامل في المدينه والتابع
للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني و وايضا في حي
الامل في المناطق الغربيه لمدينه خانيونس
هذه المناطق تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه على مدار الايام
الماضيه كان هناك ايضا استهدافات ب من
خلال الغارات الجويه ومن الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه لمنازل مدنيه فلسطينيه وهذه
المنازل جل الاستهدافات هي تطال هذه
المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه سواء في
خانيونس او سواء في مناطق مختلفه كما في
دير البلح حيث استهدفت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه منزلا في دير البلح وكان هناك
عدد من الشهداء والجرحى منزل لعائله
البحيصي وعائله البحيصي هي عائله عريقه في
دير البلح وايضا هي لديها مربعات سكنيه
تسكن هناك في دير البلح في المناطق
الغربيه وبالتالي اي قصف اسرائيلي على تلك
المناطق هو يوقع عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى
وعندما نتحدث عن دير البلح نحن نتحدث عن
منطقه كفح هي مناطق مكتظه بالسكان يطلب
الجيش الاسرائيلي من سكان المنطقه الوسطى
وايضا سك كان مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع ان
يتوجهوا الى مراكز الاواء في دير البلح
وبالتالي اي عمليه قصف اسرائيلي على تلك
المناطق بكل تاكيد توقي عشرات من الشهداء
والجرح من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط
شكرا جزيلا